JD pulled a couple of clips from the car
nation that but not a lot I won't bore
the [__] out of you but it is kind of
funny some of these things yeah the
music was what really got me just oh it
was crazy yeah King Charles gets out of
his uh Carriage you know he's got the
horses he enters the church and they're
playing this
just played when I walk in the room at
the SiriusXM
it was yeah
happening for months
I've been bother to remember one thing
every time he had to turn over to the
side and read what they were supposed to
have him say everyone was reading cue
cards the Archbishop him everyone yeah I
know his whole life he was preparing for
this and he didn't bother to learn his
part and you never knew when someone
would start singing too at one point
this Archbishop dude is talking and then
this singer sir Brynn Terrell starts
singing like like just everyone breaks
out into song like a Disney renewed
faith
a joyful hope and a commitment to serve
one another in love
[Music]
who's watching this
hey that's sir Brynn
Children of the Night what sweet music
they made
I will bite your neck and take you to
your eternal life
oh
the recognition is the part of the
ceremony where the Monarch is presented
to the people those attending are asked
to support the new king I hear present
unto you King Charles
your uncle King
wherefore all you who have come this day
to do your homage and service are you
willing to do the same
God save King Charles
oh it gives me the heebie-jeebies all of
you that have come here today to
celebrate his homage looking oh save
control
the most important part of the ceremony
is the anointing where the Archbishop
pours holy oil in a spoon and then
anoints Charles hands head and breast
his breast
in the old days the coronation oil
included intestinal wax of sperm whales
what
we now anoint thee with intestinal wax
of sperm whale and then we say makaleka
High make a hiney hole
it does go on and now receive the
well-jism on your breasts
and now Wonder Woman will put the lasso
of Truth around you
the news max Royal analyst Hillary
fordwich made it sound like Charles was
getting whale sperm poured on him the
oil was blessed his holy oil blessed in
Jerusalem but what's interesting about
what we're going to have in terms of the
the scent are you ready there's going to
be sperm and whale sperm and what
they've done is they've removed all of
the all of the um there were there were
um elf
um sperm and it's been it's now gone to
whale sperm because um Charles is vegan
that's exactly right you're absolutely
right she doesn't know what she's
talking about wow it was the intestines
received a massive whale facial from it
used to be from Kibler elves and they
changed and that was the other thing too
she goes and no he's going to get the
sperm of an elf in the old days but now
a sperm whale there's oh this is pretty
cool and I gotta credit our own who
caught this one I didn't catch this but
it is the best part of the whole
ceremony acquire was singing vivat
Regina Camilla which means Long Live
Queen Camilla uh but it really sounded
like I love vagina Camilla and it was
very I was like here is I love vagina
listen carefully
foreign
[Music]